There was a very exciting news this September 2012.
It was an announcement about 100 people's pens etc.
So it wasn't too late to announce from here.
But the news is local.  The theory is that the hustle and bustle of 113 is composed. Actually, this is
the third time, but it is a topic that the generation is finally certified for that reason.
Similar to the stores around that,
there is a list of experiments like this to generate.
First of all, it's a very fast speed near the case of light elements
. It's like 5 while accelerating to a part of the speed of
the highway.  Use it nearby and learn about your thoughts and hit it. In
this case, the local number 30 is selected near the light bottom, and the local bunker 83 is near the thoughts
.
30 + 83 is 113.
Nearly 10,000 cases fly or
hit a business, and in the end one is a heavy case and it is difficult to do it after all,
but the two Genji scents become one.
I think that this video artist's dog will like
Kikuhana.
The process of the real fur collapse series occurs when the alpha style
c is said. In my personal opinion, the most autumn scoring is the development of No.
113. The place of the experiment is in Japan.  I think it's wonderful that
you see this is the Japanese periodic table.
So if you look here, the local bank will write the Japanese flag in the development of 113.
I think it's the best that the science has spread to the lime people
.
It's the first time that modern elements have been certified in Asia, and I'm looking forward to the naming
because of the periodic table.  There is almost no name that starts with j. Originally, a German
scientist wrote this with the symbol ja of No. 13 Noah
,
but if there is a number 4 such as ja or jp in the modern periodic table, I would  Is happy
A Japanese diplomat ambassador attended a conference in the UK that the paper on 100 people No. 3 was published.
It was the first time for me to be greeted by scientific things, but I was pleased to
see you martin d have ended heading to
do.